the other day yeah
i've been busy i've been real busy
lately
but i've been doing everything for for
the better interest of people
mostly sometimes yeah and i just sit
there and i i look at the how life
is right now and it's crazier than [ __ ]
right now especially
and i look like [ __ ] you look great
you're talking about because of kovid or
because of other things
i got call it you have it nope they tell
me i don't
so um i don't know i don't know what
cove it is anymore
none of us do but i did oh guess what i
found today
are you are you recording me right now
i'm i am okay i found this thing
it was a blue uh crap
and it had little stickers like that
that that that asian um snake
oh it's um testicles thingies
oh god the little pinchers
like the snake i said god damn it
i've seen everything in life but this is
some sick [ __ ]
that's why i don't get in the ocean over
my my hip you won't find me in there
only if i'm on a boat what's the last
time you've been in the ocean it's been
a minute
and i think there it went
there's one that one just a flu donkey
right now
you spend your time during the day going
where because you drift around right
yeah so i i stay with a friend
and it's all right there you do yeah but
yeah everybody has that [ __ ]
with the rap i'm gonna take it out today
it's called what's that threats we're
gonna get rid of them today
because that's what it is there are rats
where you stay i don't know what we have
to do but i can't close it up
i have to take him out you hear me i
hear you so we got to take it out
because that doesn't really know if it
goes in the bottom of your foot that
somebody cut your foot so i
one time five years ago seven years ago
i got bit in the county jail
by a spider on the side of my head right
here and it boiled up like
in a whole bunch of little bubbles right
like a little bubble bubble
like um that morning i woke up and i
said ow it hurt so bad
well it was a spider that bit me i
didn't know what kind of spider
then i was thinking well when i was a
little girl at five years old my grandma
said
in the ceiling i'd shoot this
[Music]
down and it was like a beetle
or some kind of a spider right
in the attic not the addict but in the
ceiling
now i don't know how
what the [ __ ] it was but it was
something different
it wasn't of this this this yeah yeah
it was a street it might and i would
only hear it
very often ruby huh where where did you
grow up
corn grove gardening we talked about i
love garden
i love all the people there your
childhood was good everything was good
[Music]
everything was excellent
but then i met i don't know just
jealousy
jealousy i guess it has to be that
because i'm not going to give up
anything that i got for anybody like
i know i know what i'm going through
it's for a reason because god came and
seen me
jesus came to see me and i've seen him
two times
and he told me you're
you're god you're you're you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he told me first isn't what you said
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i said why'd
you say
[ __ ] you god i said like that because i
tell them like that sometimes
[ __ ] you god i'll tell them like that
well then i was talking to him and then
i said well what would you like sir and
he said a drink of water
and i said what'd you say sarah he said
drink water and i said okay
i'll be right back so i didn't know what
to tell him
i said do you have anything else to tell
me am i am i am okay or
i'm gonna make it to happen you didn't
answer me
i said all right lord it's nice to meet
you i said i can't believe i
just met the lord i said but um you are
my father in heaven
and you are my father on earth as well
and i said um
i don't know what else to tell you lord
i i don't know i said but i was
bored at the time i was bored like
most people wouldn't sit there and no i
was like
dude i'm out of here so i knew i wasn't
going back to water
right so he comes like another day and
he's walking down the street
and i said lord there's like a couple
maybe like four days later
i said lord what are you doing walking
this train again i said what the hell is
wrong with you why don't you go back
up to everywhere just [ __ ] watch you
i said i want to go oh
i asked him like this too but the first
time i said
dear lord it's up to you if i said nice
to meet you i said but it's up to you
if i can stay on earth or if i'm going
to heaven with you i don't know
and he said i said would you please
grant me to stay on this earth right now
i said i'm not ready to go yet home
and he didn't say nothing to me i said
um okay then so i said so he granted me
my wish
then um so the next time i met him so he
was walking this way and he said you're
a [ __ ] or some [ __ ]
uh he said you're everything and he kept
on walking
and i was like lord what's what's matter
are you mad at me
and then so he kept on walking and he
turned back around and
start walking this way and so i said hey
something right here i said you need to
send angels
to my lord right now bring your best
angels to god
in heaven i said bring them down here
and and watch over my lord
something ain't right because he's a
human being you understand
he really is he just woke up from the
dead
and he can walk on water and he's
amazing to me
but and he gives me everything i need
and
could ever want but
i don't know and right now um
i told him like this i said lord i said
if you uh
i said send the best angels from heaven
right now
for my lord because something's not
right
and the next thing i know i look down
there and he's walking and there's a
football
there's a guy he's a robot football and
he's going like this
like back and forth right just like wait
like and i said oh [ __ ]
that's what i'm talking about you know
and um yeah so i know the lord i know
i know there's demons on this earth i
know i've seen them
and i'm not high and i'm not this
because
in the drains i look and like it's a
sucker fish holding
this [ __ ] in us if it's anything it's
that suckerfish they got from
from the ocean and it's sucking and it's
not letting [ __ ] come out but it it'll
open its mouth let it out
and they come out but then i seen this
trash bag one night
it's like a trash bag and millions i
swear to god don't think i'm crazy okay
don't millions of rats was coming out of
his back
it's like a a sack or something right
and i said that's not [ __ ] possible
and we're looking
and and i'm on the street and it's
really going down
and um is the craziest thing i ever seen
in my life
is the most weirdest thing i ever seen
in my life
and i don't understand yeah just
i don't know i don't i don't get this
cove how
weird to get rats what's doing it
it's these pulls
and if i can't shut them down then i
have no
i don't know how much longer i can live
with this everybody else is living so
i'm gonna live
because i've got good people on my team
no matter what they give me my medicine
if even if it's a robot sitting in
anything they give me a shot or whatever
i need at that moment
or it's the lord or and then i when i
see the devil
i was with biggie smalls we were talking
and i just came
we could before i couldn't find him yes
where were you he said on an island and
i said oh yeah he said yes
all right then you're you're vacationing
huh he said yeah whatever yeah
say yeah well you're back here though so
whatever you want to stay here
in your apartment what do you want what
do you want so why do you camp out here
in this [ __ ]
[ __ ] hole of a tucking desert why are we
here
so what of all places la here why can't
we be in downtown l.a when it's really
[ __ ]
rough and [ __ ] you know
ruby what do you dream about do you
sleep either i don't dream
you don't dream i don't i just sleep and
when i sleep i can and somebody can kill
me and i don't know it
i'll bet my friend he stabs me in the
head
with the knife and i'll go out for a
minute
and he'll he'll wake me up when he's
pulling it out
he's crazier than [ __ ] he's my friend
though and he's a nut he said not even
my boyfriend told me you're killing me
[Music]
i said just me why me why do you always
pick me to do that he said because i
wanted to try it one time
see if i could wake you up i said all
right then bro you did it
so he did it again he said i just had to
chance myself one more time i said
that's it
no more times okay and he said okay
but yeah that's weird like life is weird
how all these people are coming back
and i haven't woken one up for a while
because i don't want to right now
i don't know but i know i woke the lord
back up
he was dead i know somebody killed him
i know that for a fact and and um i woke
him back up
so and there's girls and women that have
died and they come by me and i'm just
like wow and
my friends the first thing they do is
they come and see me
as soon as they wake up everybody comes
and sees me
the weirdest thing i've ever met seen in
my life
why i have that gift i'll never know why
god has picked me to be this
i don't know anymore i'm like
i hate everything right now
just because they targeted me
and um
i never did nothing to nobody well i
want to see my people and i'm going to
no matter where they're at i'm going to
find them
i don't care whenever i unlock that one
door down
in that cellar wherever it was
eighteen hundred feet or
sixteen hundred feet and underneath
ground and
there's one elevator up and one down you
wouldn't be scared
that must take like ten minutes to get
down
to where you're going
or even a little longer maybe 15-20
minutes
and to know that you're never coming out
of that and spotting it
i couldn't do it to anybody
so i've learned a lot like cortell has
always taught me
because um they have the best
they are the terminator i'm not lying to
you they have
they've cloned people thank god
jesus showed me this big thing it's like
a cell
and i said well how are you [ __ ]
stacking those [ __ ] i asked him
like that
how you stack him
i said wow i said so you cloned every
person that you want
and he said yeah so i said you taught my
dad how to do that [ __ ] huh
or what what what because my friends
one of them right here 17
16 1677 he was born
another one reset there fernandez he
told me he was born in 1739.
um i have a hermaphrodite friend
she was back in the
uh i don't know where they had big
parades and there was big ass
elephants huge ones and they're like
little people
like like uh the jubilee not the gypsy
days
[ __ ] like that and i'm just like is this
[ __ ] really real or are they just
[ __ ] with me
like is this all really real
i don't know
you know because i mean
i don't know but today is the day
i said today is the day it's coming out
no matter what
because i found that blue thing now
there's nothing
else in my body
i got it for sure i got it
so what i asked this question of a lot
of people in that interview what to
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
the most important lesson um
always to study
never stop learning that's the most
important thing
when i heard that when i was like i
think i was five years old when i heard
that
my teacher said never stop learning
there's anything
we'd go in class she'd say good good
morning you never stop learning
today we're gonna learn that's a hard
thing
so like yeah i always am doing and
that's why maybe i have the worst case
maybe
but right now at this time
um i had to get it all out and then i
gotta
then you got it then you gotta as soon
as i get it out of me
and i tell you guys sew up go get
some um you get a what is that called um
um super glue and you glue up
your inside that's what you do
it was super glue i swear to god
that's the only thing because it has to
be fast because
when i got the stitches in my head when
somebody hit me over the head with the
brick real hard
and cracked my whole skull open my skull
is still cracked
in apple valley a long time ago but
yeah uh i don't know
i can't explain it ruby you're so
fascinating
god and i want it out so bad it's like
why don't you just like
fester out of there or something it's
this one
when i go outside i'm gonna do it watch
do it all right ruby thanks for coming
coming by again yes sir brother ah
i'm not crazy i haven't lost my mind i'm
not going to a mentor ward
and and i do this for him because i like
my friends
he i hate saying he's my friend because
it's really scary
life out there and i hate that
word right now friend because it's so
scary for you guys
and when he they logged downstairs i
said all right
that's whenever i'll be checking that's
why i don't leave here right now
so my people they're watching you at all
times
and you'll be sick i promise you that
i believe that that's great to know yes
sir or i'm
i'm doing everything i can to protect
you
because i have my ways so i know
if you're in here not for they can't do
it no more even if it's upstairs
downstairs i don't give a [ __ ] what they
try
side to side they can't keep you in here
now that's what's weird
the equator's right across the street do
you know that the equator
the equator that door listen to me that
door across the street
it's hollow the
the equator it's right in underneath us
i don't know how they leveled the deck
but it's a hole all the way down and it
goes around
i don't know how far in this city but
it's right here
i swear by god on my life i asked the
the wetbacks right
i said is it right here and he said yep
because i caught i found it one day
and he said yes it is and i said i found
it finally
so the the real not the equator but the
like involving a little pit to go down
down down down
is right across the street so if you
need to dispose of any bodies i'd tell
them to drop it right there
you'll get rid of everything thank you
yes sir
that's the truth brother you hear me
you're always sad i will i wouldn't lie
to you
that's what that's what they told me and
the rye
oh yeah will you hit me with that thing
you got a better one today